The joe rogan experience.
Preposterous.
I said it.
I did say I can't help myself.
You must be a Michigan guy.
He has a very prodigious vocabulary.
It's preposterous.
Has been the word of the month.
Oh is it?
Yeah.
I've been blasting it out.
Every time it comes into my stupid head,
it gets it the in a groove where you can stop saying you got their words.
That definitely,
cause you remember when you saw,
every used to say was the first one I ever heard said whatever bananas.
He's just a little whatever.
You were the first one that made that inflection and it's spread all over the
valley.
What ever you did,
you were the first one?
Yeah,
years ago.
[inaudible] first one I ever heard say it and then everybody started saying it
and then he didn't say it as much.
What did I say?
I don't understand what you're saying.
You know you'd be talking about like something that would piss you off and you
know what ever,
you know instead like the,
instead of saying whatever you made that beat what ever and then I didn't know I
did that.
I really have no idea.
I go,
Joe,
I know you so much.
My friends,
we've known each other a long time.
Tell me more.
Tell me what we'd known each other since the 90s.
Early now and then we met back in the day when I was living in New York.
Sorry I'm really bad at it.
Caroline's or at um,
uh,
Amsterdam billiards wants to,
we just ran into each other.
Dom Railroad can shoot a hell of a game of pool.
Tell her that.
I'm going to start saying that Joe was what ever
the pause that makes it so unique and mind.
Pause the middle of what an average.
That's where all the brilliance lies.
You know it used to crack me up when people go to me like whatever,
like you know,
like think you're going to take credit for like that.
And then it was the first one I heard.
But like people would say to me,
does it bother you that the sopranos do Bada Boom,
Bada Bang?
I go,
no,
they go,
but you did it before them.
I go,
well cause I was around before the show started.
I didn't make up acting Italian.
I didn't make up,
forget about it,
you know.
Well I was the first one that should forget about it.
I had a nasty thing happened to me last night.
I dropped my iPhone in my beer,
hold it out real fast,
and then I just did the first thing I'd find out,
but I'll suck all the beer out of the like sucking the holes like as hard as
that shit was coming in my mouth.
But then like something like a slime thing flew mouth.
I'm like,
was that your wax or what the fuck was that?
So I don't know if it was orange for my half and,
and,
or if it was a battery,
I,
you gotta have a vice and dude,
just stop it.
There was a piece of orange,
I was like your beer and had simple orange.
I'm your,
I'm going to be your Colombel on their swing.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with him?
There's anything wrong with them.
I've been working with his fucking asshole for a decade.
He doesn't need anything wrong with him.
He thinks it's me.
He was like,
you know,
you just,
you're just tense.
You're from the east coast.
You crazy with all that karate.
See,
the interesting thing is that I,
the word retarded convene with shoes,
but there is something we'll do respect to something like retard esque about you
look even that vacant look that he has.
Yeah,
it's my age difference.
Well it think so.
I mean everybody your age actually got a 37 year olds are rocking it.
Like,
yeah,
I'm 37 and I rock it like a 22 year old,
which is different.
But that's Oscar.
You rock.
What?
What do you rock?
I'm rocking it.
Nintendo shirt right now.
Do you think,
I wonder if he's a Manchild what man?
Yeah.
A lot of them work in like the computer industry.
A lot of Manchild in the comic book world,
you didn't know what your target market is.
You get this Gig.
I mean,
of all the people,
Joe knows what the fuck you doing over there.
I have ones and Zeros.
I understand what he's like is it is,
this is a contradiction in terms.
He's like a really bright retard.
You know,
like,
I mean that's what I mean.
I don't know how else to put it.
Like my Facebook,
Modo,
that should be your new a thing on your message board.
You know,
he doesn't have any happiness like a retarded kid.
You know the joy that they have with a smile.
He's pretty happy.
Pretty happy.
Go for it.
You hanging out with more?
Yeah.
I always hang out with all these porn star friends.
You're really fucking porn stars.
Fuck yeah,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Wow.
He's got a new fate every time.
The kid just when you think he can't just,
he can't add a different flair.
This is no more flares to add.
Does
this Retardo Martha bomb over here?
I got so much good feedback calling you or retard the cool thing to do.
Yeah.
That's one thing that's weird about opening for bands.
They will tune up while you're on onstage.
Well,
in that level yet.
I mean when I work with share,
it was classy because she was the one that there was the by far the best job I
ever had an opening for anybody because she knows she had a great crowd.
She had transvestites and mothers with the grandmothers,
with their grandchildren.
That was the audience.
Yeah.
ECLECTIC.
If you know what the security told me,
if they ever saw a single straight guy alone this thing and he looked straight,
they would,
they would track him all night because no,
no guy along goes through a Cher concert.
If you're straight,
well that's a gay guy dancing and happy.
No problem.
So if someone's going to be like a crazy stalker,
it's going to be a straight straight guy.
But she was fun though.
Yeah.
You enjoyed working with her,
right?
Yeah,
I really liked her.
Do you ever feel like a friendship with her?
Do you contact her?
I'm not anymore.
But you know she's,
she's very isolated.
Yeah,
she's a good person.
And Yeah,
she was like,
she used to ask me about the world.
Like,
she wasn't really in it cause she wasn't really in it to go,
well what's it like and you,
you know,
she asked me about people and one night we went to,
I said,
I talked to her in the going out in Montreal.
look,
why don't you drop the outfits?
Stop wearing a top hat and a cane.
I like,
maybe nobody will notice.
I can just fix her with the fucking tails,
the dead,
skipping back and forth on Ridge.
And she is,
you know,
so we go to an ice cream place and some like old guy go in and look with French
guy.
Hey,
aren't you a famous one?
What's her name?
And that's all she had to hear it.
She goes,
yeah,
who could ever forget all,
what's your name?
So then now that validated that she can't go out,
you know.
But I have one guy,
that's it.
Yeah.
But we had a good time.
You know,
we say it was a funny thing in the casino.
We would meet when I like in the,
in the arenas,
I would do my act,
then they'd have a break and then she'd come up.
So we'd never see each other except when she had it,
like a team prayer.
And sometimes I was in that.
But um,
when,
when she's,
we would cross each other one night her grandmother and grandfather were there
and she said to me,
she goes,
you just did a Jewish joke when my grandparents there.
And I said,
and by the way,
your answers out and your grandfather's looking at it.
And she stopped the left.
Well,
it was that one video she did where she was on like a battleship to turn back
time.
I think it was fuck could turn back time.
Joe,
he got a little charity,
some sheriffs on.
Yeah,
me too.
Gypsies,
tramps and teas.
I didn't like halfbreed which was happen,
have prayed.
But I did.
I loved the,
the Bob Dylan Song.
She covered sound Goddamn ball.
I really want to do with baby,
be friends with you.
She's run a cannon.
We get up with that hair.
Jesus.
Hey Joey,
put the,
uh,
the song on the net.
Uh,
what is it called?
Itunes I tube.
I tune are you do?
Yeah,
it's called a just a disappointing further.
The one you played last time you were here?
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Well you doing any music back when you were opening for these people?
No,
but I did one time,
it come out at Madison Square Garden.
We weren't at the big room that we were doing the,
the smallest of any 500 to the pellet form where they used to box and she,
this is so funny about her home.
I the good,
the band wants me to go out and pick playing a guitar and she was singing a
song,
something about the something fire wheels of fire,
some song.
And I get,
I get out there and I'm playing,
I'm not really playing that.
He's the guys behind the Scrim,
the real guitar players playing his ass off and I'm thinking like I'm planning,
she's at that,
I'm singing with her on the song.
We get down on her knees and we're like looking at each other and singing and
screaming.
And then I get off and she never said a word about it.
She never said,
what the fuck are you doing?
That was great.
That was going to be,
and I worked with her for all those years.
You know,
you'd think she would notice this one stage.
What was it?
Song.
But he's singing,
I forget,
but it was pretty lucky.
It was a good rock song,
you know?
And it would be something gimme shelter is up.
Oh Wow.
What now?
How many different gigs did you do?
Whitney Houston.
They're just,
the weekend was a little long weekend and I,
I think I opened for her three,
it's three nights.
And then it was like a long lake,
like Memorial Day or July 4th,
something like that.
And then I,
I did a,
uh,
my own headlines the first time.
My headline was on the fourth night and I did a whole bit about her,
like make fun of her and,
and singing and stuff.
And then the crew was crying,
laughing.
That's hilarious.
And her father was such a good guy and he,
I felt like he said to me,
you know,
I really like you.
You're,
I said,
thanks.
He goes,
I'd love to get a little break with my daughter again.
I said thank you.
And I'm thinking,
no fucking way.
I'd rather be at Jimmy's clam bar and bail afforded before they shucked the
clams
have them shocking in the backyard.
But anyway,
it was that bad,
Huh?
Yeah.
She,
you know,
she like,
I remember saying on stage,
cause you know,
then she's already doing the prayer and look,
and Jesus does in his hand.
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know about a lot about religious history and I don't think Jesus had 300
pimp bouncers pushing old people away.
You know?
I mean,
she pushed old people away.
Well,
you know,
I'm exactly the kind of shit that had the divas thing.
I couldn't stand for that.
Diva Shit is weird,
right?
Yeah.
Man.
Senior was a lightweight,
so that was 135 pounds.
Um,
and I think that,
uh,
I think that fight took place as a lightweight fighter.
Believe fought Livingstone bramble he found a lot of great fighters.
SARC whale.
He came to see me at the Improv one night and uh,
we went out to talk and his wife and his kid,
we're watching a show and some guy comes up to us and it goes boom,
boom and seen.
He goes,
can I ask you something when you hit me?
Right?
And I said to the guy,
I said,
look,
uh,
you know,
I said,
they can't hit you.
You know,
Raymond's really nice guy.
Do you ever meet him?
I'm said hi to him downstairs with them.
You know,
Youngstown,
Ohio,
like real cool guy and did it all for his father.
A great story.
And I said,
look man,
he can't hit you.
You know,
like Raymond's like,
he's,
and they said,
well,
can I hit you then to rape me?
I said,
no,
you can't fucking pay them.
What are you crazy kind of hit you?
He said,
good.
I always wanted to see what like a professional punch felt like,
oh God.
Like the fuck I look like to give them an amateur punch.
Well now he that dummy,
the guy's got to his fucking hands and then put gloves on.
Then punch.
You either break his hands course with the force that they hit.
Yeah,
you could easily break your hand.
Someone's forehead.
He's lucky he didn't say it at the Vinny Corto if any would have probably
punched him.
Oh God.
I did a great thing of anyone time ever tell you this.
I Dunno.
I brought him up.
Okay.
We had a crazy fucking nut cocaine head that lived upstairs and they were funny
today when this,
yeah,
they would fuck.
And then you hear the shower and it was like five in the morning and I stay up
late.
But after a while,
like I said,
the Musky turned the music down just a little.
That's all nice.
You know,
next day Kim's window was broken in a car.
I knew he fucking did it.
So I go get Vinny.
Vinny looked like a fucking,
you know,
incredibly fucking gorilla.
Just killed 100% and I get,
I get a kick out of him.
And I liked the guy personally,
but,
uh,
he did me a favor,
come,
we go up and was like,
good guy,
bad guy thing.
And he kicked the door and the kid goes,
what?
And I go,
hey man,
I just want to ask any sees Vinny.
And then he changed completely and he goes,
uh,
you know,
my cup.
I just wanted to tell you that somebody broke a window.
And as your neighbor,
I want to warn you that there's somebody around here.
So just look out for yourself.
And I'm totally not really me.
And Vinnie goes,
my fucking cousin,
he goes,
I love him like a brother.
He goes,
if anybody does fucks with dom,
I get these fucking headaches.
I don't even know what I'm doing.
And the kids going.
And the guy goes,
oh,
no,
no ma'am,
I certainly didn't do it.
And Go,
holy fuck accused you of doing it.
Why would you say that?
And,
and he goes,
he said,
I sleep on his couch and the afternoon,
make sure there's no fucking noise.
I'll go fucking crate.
And that was it.
You know,
stop.
The noise stopped,
everything,
stopped everything that he'd see him at the Jimmy see Benny impressive 500
pounds at the gym.
Yeah.
How you doing?
How's your cousin?
I ended,
the thing I realized about myself was that I love violence,
but it has to be real.
Like I don't like violent movies than it,
than it did it and like to see Joey Peshy a 60 year old guy beaten up some 20
year old kid.
No fucking bullshit.
When I was there that night when you invited me to the pond and I see these guys
really getting fucking whacked and,
and you know,
you,
we know when it really hits.
The reality is when you sit in,
like I told you,
I was sitting behind the guy's mother and girlfriend when he got knocked down
and the mother's like,
chew me,
you know,
like real,
it's fucking,
you know,
I loved the pounding they take.
Yeah,
it's odd.
I can't remember the kid that Tasmanian Devil is just ran up the thing and did
like flips over.
Do you remember him talking about it was kind of maybe he was like maybe Mulatto
or maybe from an island or something.
He's kind of a light skin black kid and he was phenomenal.
He was,
he was leaping in the air like eight feet.
And I'm talking about y'all.
I do.
I can't believe I don't have his name on the top line.
Hold on.
How,
but he was,
it was like they spread the camera up when you were watching him,
you know he was the one that knocked the guy out.
Yeah,
I have to,
I have to find out what his name is right now because he's fucking brilliant and
he's an up and coming kid.
So just give me a,
so while we're waiting,
let's talk more about supplements.
Hey Tom,
what was it like meeting Johnny Carson with,
do you have any stories of anything cool that,
that,
that happened?
The thing about it is,
and that was like in 1986 so that's when the tonight show is still really big.
And it was not fun.
It was a,
it was an experience like a,
um,
an imprimatur of comedy.
It was an experience.
John.
John,
Shit,
sorry,
I keep calling shiny shit.
Uh,
but Carson,
I,
I wanted to,
I looked in the hills in Burbank and I wonder to run away,
I wanted to run away and start a new life like in the hills because I was so
fucking afraid of going on that stage when they,
cause Jim Mccauley,
the guy booked that comes and talks to you and then they pull it back in.
There it is.
John Dodson.
Sorry.
You know what's his name?
John Dodson.
That was the kid.
Yeah,
he's amazing.
Oh my God.
What an athlete.
He moves like a cartoon flies through the air.
Yeah.
It's just super talented.
He was doing that flip.
He was like right up the walls.
Yeah.
He's incredible.
He's a,
yeah,
he does like cartoonish shit.
It's like self,
like so gifted.
You know,
he's just got like a,
almost like an acrobatic ability to throw the story.
Whatever you're saying.
You were terrified.
Terrified to go on the stage.
The curtain go back and it's unreal that you hear Johnny Carson laughing and Ed
Mcmahon rule and see,
I had done a joke,
but at Mcmahon and when,
when I saw him backstage,
he pulled me towards him.
I think,
oh,
fucking head's going to slide me right before I go on because he and I actually,
I didn't know that he loved the joke,
but remember the joke?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was like,
um,
you call them alcohol slow.
What do I call?
I said I met Ed Mcmahon.
He's,
you know,
he's been in show business for 35 years.
What do I go up to him and say hi Ed.
Like call him Mister Ed.
Mr He was the Eddie Mcmahon.
Mr You,
big fat,
lucky town,
one slump kissing Johnny's ass for the last 30 years.
You Budweiser's suck on an ALP was slinging nothing.
What do you do?
I don't mean that in the,
and that was the joke.
Right.
And you know,
not a nice joke,
but hopefully,
you know,
he took it in the spirit that he was a big success and I was a new comic and
that's the way you took it,
you know?
That's awesome.
I watched Johnny Carson every single day.
I never missed it and I was a kid and that was because there was no VCRs when I
was a kid.
But I would sit there and watch it every day.
I think I remembered you from that.
When I first moved to La,
I met you at the comedy store and I was like,
from Johnny Carson saw young Carson,
I saw a bunch of guys on Carson that wouldn't have been great comedians.
I saw Jenny on Carson for the first time.
It was a great community.
He was a great comedian as needed.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
Carson was the thing back when you were coming up,
if you got on Carson,
Holy Shit,
you fucking made it.
I know he would see a guy like Richard Jenny,
you had like 18 Carson's or something like that.
Yeah.
And you really got writer.
Brilliant.
And,
and just such a great comic and you would,
you'd see those uh,
those credits and you go Jesus Christ,
like I did Carson 18 times,
then you would go see him.
And of course like he was at the time when I first saw Jenny was like in the
80s,
he was a master,
a master.
I remember just being in awe and there was a bunch of other comedians that were
at the uh,
east side comedy club member,
east side in Long Island.
Richard Medivation.
Yup.
Richard Meyer Vini,
me and Kevin James.
We're sitting around after the show and we're shaking her head where like God
damn,
he's good.
God dammit.
He apparently did two different hours on a Friday night.
He did two shows in eight and a 10,
two completely different hours,
completely top to bottom.
And they were like,
is both of them or slaughtering?
He has just a destroyer running writer.
I remember feeling like what he could take premises that you didn't think there
was anything there and you could turn them into like one of your favorite bits.
Like you did a premise about buying a corvette and the guy tried to talk them
into all sorts of stuff in the corvette.
And I remember thinking while he was doing this,
wow,
how is this guy going to make this funny?
This is talking about buying an expensive sports car and he's gonna figure out
how to make this funny number,
the ref thing he did.
I had a bunch of great the football,
we know he,
we have problems,
him and I,
and it really was because of him.
And I'm not saying that clearly.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
because he's dead.
No,
but what happened was we were like getting different things at the same time.
You know each other.
Well he was competitive with me and I think,
cause people pitted us against each other purely because we were short Italians
while I'm a short Italian as well.
But you've never been nothing but supportive and Nice,
tight Joseph.
But I mean nothing.
You know,
I,
one time I said to him,
because there was,
somebody was talking about,
I said,
why don't we go out on the road together?
Oh yeah,
we'll fill up theaters.
And he goes,
why would I want to do that?
I said,
I dunno.
Make money to have fun.
You know,
he didn't understand the concept.
Yeah.
He said to me one time,
he goes,
Montreal comedy festival.
You think I should go there?
I said,
go with the idea that you're going to meet beautiful girls.
Go to great restaurants and then if you happen to get a deal you do but have
fun.
And he goes fun.
He looked at me like,
what?
What do you mean fun?
This isn't fun.
This is,
he was tortured.
Wow.
He never enjoyed it,
you know?
That's the saddest part of it.
He was,
he never knew how good he was there.
He never enjoyed how good he was.
I first met him in Montreal.
Yeah.
I first met him and like,
well,
isn't that where I met you or Yup.
Yup.
I met him and uh,
94 just so we were both passing each other and in the front doors just said,
hi.
Hey Man.
Nice to meet you,
blah,
blah.
Which shows you doing that kind of thing.
Just,
you know,
and he seemed to me like he just was a,
just a brilliant,
brilliant mind,
like a pro,
but just the,
he's,
you know,
and had maybe almost too much.
I saw him on a plane I was getting,
I was flying back.
Remember they three cabins and the American and the notice in First Class,
and he was in coach with Lenny.
Lenny Clarke.
Nola had clerked Lynnie I forget his Lenny Shoultz crazy lending.
Crazy lint.
No,
not that crazy.
And not to one more pigs were shit late.
Yeah,
but what are the Lenny,
they pull out the ones friend.
He would know them.
Okay.
But anyway,
uh,
he spent,
I walked back to say hi,
and he goes,
you know,
I don't,
I usually apply first myself,
but I'm plying him.
I said,
okay.
I went,
it's all right.
I didn't fly.
ABC flew me and he didn't like that either.
I'm thinking,
I didn't know.
Do I that to rub it in?
And then I finally said to him,
rich,
what do you want me to do?
You want my cookie?
I'm just in first class.
Not a big fucking deal.
You guys are so Italian.
That's such an Italian.
I fucking cool.
They have the good Salami over there.
Fucking Salamis get to nitrates.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's a tough,
it's a tough lesson for those guys that are like super competitive and loaners.
It's a tough lesson as you start getting older that none of this shit is fun if
you don't have friends.
Yeah.
You know what we're talking about?
Last night we were all hanging out is you and me Kreischer and uh,
Josh Martin and all the,
uh,
Jessie Mae Peluso,
we're all hanging out with the lab.
She's great.
She's so great,
but we're all laughing and having a great time and you know,
we're all comics,
you know?
Yeah.
That's what it's all about was to be like that.
It's supposed to be,
we see each other,
we hug each other and decided,
I remember when I went to see the premiere of a Batman,
the very first one,
and Jack Nicholson was in it and he was at the bar and just fucking drink.
And it's cheers where everybody and prince was there,
this little little,
you know,
kind of faggoty prints go,
whatever you say.
Faggoty Shit.
No,
but anyway,
he's sitting there,
Joe,
he's got two body guards sitting in front of me sitting there and he's not,
and I'm thinking,
what fun is it?
Why don't you talk to somebody?
It feels like royalty though.
I mean the guy named himself prince,
how shocking is that?
He wants to be treated like royalty with giant men guarding his flesh.
Right.
These P,
by the way,
he's got to get into my car.
I have an idea.
He had some high heels on it too.
I guess he wrote the music for that.
But anyway,
it just struck me about the here's Nicholson easily,
just as famous if not more than him.
And,
and he was like miserable.
Nicholson's all having fun.
Well,
you know the person,
you know,
I taught fourth grade and now those kids are grown ups and that's really cool
because some of them told me it was the best year of their lives.
They come to see me do stand up.
Oh,
that's amazing.
Very cool.
Will you teach and what fourth grade until you know everything but all fourth
graders like different than science,
everything.
I mean,
yeah,
it's different than what you did because you went to set people who had like an
interest and a love for something and when to to explore it.
You weren't,
you were doing,
but mine is different.
They had to be there.
So my thing was self doubt,
self esteem.
I figure I can't teach these subjects are going to come and go in and lives,
but teaching them self esteem and some of the most rewarding things were like,
uh,
I had this one kid who was real shy.
He was so shy,
he was real tall and he was embarrassed by it.
And he would stay in the SEL in the cloak,
cloak room,
they'd call it,
you know,
where all the coats and he'd just stay in there.
And when to come out I go sky,
it was to calm sky king because he was a space cadet goes sky,
you got to come out.
He can't stay.
I can't let a kid just sitting,
you know.
And by the end of me just like work in his self esteem and all.
He was in the middle of the class,
just what everybody else waving his hand.
And his mother came up to me and she was like really touched by it and told me
that I changed his and then you know,
that kind of Shit's cool.
And now I got like a couple of the girls come to see me as she goes,
one of the girls goes,
uh,
Turner or why did you let us do so much stuff?
You know,
like I said,
because you were smarter than me.
I said,
she'd go to me.
look,
you know,
I'm heading more knowledge because I was an adult.
But you know,
you kids,
a lot of you have more brainpower to me.
I mean,
I know I wasn't dumb.
I was smart enough to know that I was in,
that's why you ran the class,
you know what I mean?
So you were an easy teacher.
That's what was really easy.
I told them at the beginning of the year,
I said,
look,
I want this to be the most fun year of your life.
Only you can mess it up.
I said,
fucking awesome opportunity.
That must've been,
I said,
I want to go to the gym.
This is one I was playing basketball and I said,
I want to go to the gym more than you do.
So the re you know we're going to have a party every Friday afternoon.
Well I would have,
we would have like kids that would do break dancing and stuff and really?
Yeah,
it was awesome.
It was great.
Did you ever try to pitch that as a sitcom?
A No,
but somebody else had an idea for a couple of times with it would be hilarious.
[inaudible] it seems like a natural,
yeah.
You as a,
as a a funny teacher because you really did it.
It's legit and if you really stop and think about it,
that would be like for a kid that's like one of the greatest rolls of the dice a
kid can get for their fourth grade teacher.
Yeah.
Edit girl up tower.
Rare.
For your fourth grade teacher.
She still calls me Mister I,
she's 26 years old.
All right.
26 27 whatever.
And then she calls me mister I rarer right.
And I go,
uh,
Theresa,
first of all,
you're taller than me.
She's always hot blonde.
I go,
he stopped with the Mr. I either call me dumb cause I just can't call you the
and that funny like she's got,
he's got me down as Mr. I rare.
That's good.
That will keep you from being a dirty birds.
Whoa,
whoa.
We stay away.
Dot.
You notice that she's a little girl.
Let him talk.
Call you.
Miss Darby is trying to establish boundaries.
Somebody said,
why do you go bro?
So young I go,
cause I can come on.
Oh Geez.
Oh,
is testing on this on is it sounds just the word hello.